et on passe maintenant à une entreprise
qui ne connaît pas la crise nos deux
invités sur ce plateau travaillent chez
McDonald's dont le siège est basé à
Guill enc et ils viennent nous parler de
la journée des métiers qui aura lieu le
16 avril bonsoir bonsoir donc nous
recevons loï Glou qui est gérant de
restaurant de l'enseigne et Débora
legluè qui est assistante de direction
c'est ça eu au restaurant de plaisir oui
alors donc c'est un événement qui aura
lieu dans toute la France environ 150
villes si si je j'ai bien compris dont
celle de plaisir euh donc une journée
des métiers en général on s'attend à ce
que ce soit l'initiative d'une
institution là donc c'est une entreprise
pourquoi ce choix peut-être l'iglou tout
simplement parce que nous souhaitions
bah communiquer sur sur nos métiers sur
sur ce qu'on sait faire chez McDonald's
on est présent depuis plus de 30 ans
maintenant sur sur le marché français et
et on connaît assez mal les métiers de
McDonald's donc on souhaitait faire en
sorte que nos équipe puisse les
présenter à à des invités qui qui se
sont inscrits au préalable sur le site
de ce fait donc c'est c'est aussi se
faire connaître finalement faire
connaître aussi la marque puisque il y a
eu une une communication très très
importante on a vu laffiche dans pas mal
de de de journaux de voilà ça notre
marque est connue je pense que nos
métiers en revanche sont sont encore le
sont moins et donc ils sont à découvrir
et ce sont vraiment les équipes des
restaurants qui vont qui vont les
présenter donc asse ass persones sous
quelle forme justement ça va être une
visite ça va être comment ça va se
passer donc sur le site de mcdonald's.fr
chaque personne pouvit s'inscrire et
s'inscrire à des sessions qui vont durer
à peu près 1h30 donc on a à peu près
quatre sessions par par jour et et donc
pendant 1h30 nos équipes vont vont
présenter à la fois leur métier les les
opportunités de carrière chez McDonald's
la formation tout le système qui qui est
mis en place pour que nos salariés
s'épanouissent dans nos restaurants
alors justement Débora degliè vous
faites partie de de l'équipe de du
restaurant de plaisir et vous allez
recevoir du coup les les visiteurs oui
quel va être votre rôle ce jour-là alors
ce jour-là en fait je vais devoir tout
simplement présenter mon métier en
expliquant une journée type et en
expliquant également mon parcours en
fait pourquoi je suis rentrée chez
McDonald's comment j'ai fait pour
arriver à ce centre de direction et
éventuellement ventter également ma
fierté de travailler chez McDonald's
justement pourquoi vous y êtes rentré et
Comand c'est fait l'évolution alors
alors je suis rentrée donc cela fait 7
ans maintenant en fait j'étais lycéenne
et cela faisait 3 ans enfin c'est là au
bout de la troisème fois que j'ai
postulé que j'ai réussi à rentrer dans
cette entreprise au début j'étais trop
jeune en fait et donc à cette époque là
le restaurant ça les intéressait pas
d'avoir des personnes mineures je c ça a
changé depuis non oui depuis nous
effectivement nous recrutons également
des mineurs l'année d'après je m'étais
pris trop tard bah oui j'avais pas fait
attention donc au mois de juillet et
l'année d'après il m'ont enfin dit oui
alors pour moi c'était vraiment bah
c'était vraiment un choix parce que du
coup j'ai quitté le lycée et c'est vrai
en fait j'avais des amis qui avaient
travaillé j'étais cliente on va dire
comme beaucoup de personnes et c'était
quelque chose qui m'attirait vraiment ce
contact avec la clientèle et puis ce
travail dynamique en fait c'est vraiment
l'image que j'avais donc une bonne
ambiance et un travail dynamique et puis
surtout un travail complet parce que en
fait nous sommes totalement polyvalents
et donc j'ai eu le plaisir donc de
travailler au restaurant je suis rentrée
en tant qu'équipière polyvalente j'étais
à 20h par semaine et au bout de 2 mois
on m'a proposé de passer au test à 35h
donc forcément j'ai dit oui et alors là
ça m'a encore plus conforté dans mon
choix parce qu'au bout de 2 mois j'avais
un vrai travail un vrai métier et j'ai
pu prendre mon indépendance et mon
autonomie vous nous dites c'est un
véritable choix vous vouliez y rentrer
même y faire carrière et y rester c'est
pas forcément toujours le cas c'est vrai
que quand on échange aussi avec des
étudiants ça peut qui qui font ce ce
boulot en boulot d'appoint en plus de
leurs études ça peut leur sembler
difficile au quotidien ils n'ont pas
forcément envie d'y rester ça a été
perçu comment par votre entourage ils
étaient ils étaient un peu surpris parce
que forcément j'avais quitté le lycée
donc pour eux c'était quittter le lycée
les études c'était la sécurité mais
aujourd'hui moi McDonald's ça a été le
meilleur choix que j'ai fait de ma vie
parce que cela fait 7 ans que je suis
assistante de direction si tout va bien
je vais même continuer ma carrière et
c'est vrai que au début ils ont eu
peut-être un petit peu peur en se disant
mais mince c'est peut-être que
McDonald's mais ils voient que je suis
tellement fier et épanoui dans mon
métier au contraire ils sont heureux
quoi c'est ce qui ce qui vous a plu en
fait dans dans votre parcours c'est
finalement qu'il y a eu une évolution
oui c'est un petit peu en fait la
démarche que que souhaite faire
McDonald's c'est conserver finalement
ses salariés en leur proposant de monter
dans les postes exactement on a
aujourd'hui dans nos équipes de gestion
on a 70 % de nos nos de nos équipes de
gestion nos salariés qui sont issus de
de McDonald's du terrain Débora en est
un exemple moi j'en suis un aussi je
suis rentré il y a 22 ans j'étais
assistant de direction comme Débora et
aujourd'hui j'ai une entreprise de 2000
salariés donc la chance est est donnée à
tout le monde chez McDonald's pour pour
évoluer et c'est c'est un petit peu ce
qu'on va ce qu'on va montrer et ce dont
vont parler les équipiers et et le le
personnel des restaurants donc le 16
avril finalement il y a quand même des
personnes qui sont recrutées sans être
passé par le bas de l'échelon aussi on a
aussi des recrutements directement de
managers en bac bac+ 2 bac+ 3 et vous
direz que c'est une méthode américaine
en fait le self made on va dire c'est
une méthode mdonal c'est une une marque
américaine mais une entreprise bien
française et on a votre politique est
gérée par McDonald France et non pas par
tout à fait on est géré par McDonald
France nous sommes tous
français alors donc on voit donc qu'il y
a des perspectives d'évolution des
volontés de de conserver vos vos
salariés vous déclarez même premier
recruteur de France tout à fait on a
effectivement on est premier recruteur
de France on recrute aussi beaucoup de
jeunes aujourd'hui donc c'est période
difficile c'est un un atout important et
qu'on souhaite partager on va recruter
près de près de 43000 personnes cette
année 3000 pour nos ouvertures donc on a
une quarantaine d'ouvertures prévu 3000
créations de postees 3000 créations de
postees et et le reste donc pour
renouveler nos équipes qui sont
effectivement composé pour beaucoup
d'étudiants et ça veut dire que les
étudiants ne restent pas tous non plus
hein exemple vous AZ qué mais aussi des
étudiants qui VI tout à fait les
étudiants pour pour certains
effectivement ne souhait pas rester
reste le temps de la la période scolaire
et ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
roulements 40000 donc cette année qui de
postes de gens qui de jeunes pour la
plupart qui vont partir qui sont
renouvelés oui c'est ça sur 66000 sur
plus de 66000 salariés effectivement
40000 vont être renouvlés on on parlait
juste avant cette chronique au déb cette
chronique d'un forum sur les jobs d'été
est-ce que du coup McDonald's est petit
de prendre des jeunes l'été nous avons
une politique de recrutement qui est qui
est euh là je parle de des restaurants
des dont je m'occupe dans lesines
restaurant on recrute tout au long de
l'année on recrute l'été pour
effectivement remplacer les salariés qui
partent en vacances mais on recrute avec
en recrutant des C on embauche en CDI et
on ne fait pas de différenciation sur le
recrutement l'été voilà les seuls les
seuls contrats que vous proposez sont
des CDI tout à fait c'est quelque chose
qui vous avveit intéressé peut-être en
entrant dans cette entreprise oui bien
sûr c'est bah c'est la sécurité de
l'emploi c'est vrai que un CDI justement
moi j'ai quitté le lycée donc j'ai
quitté une situation entre guillemets
sûre pour justement un emploi mais quand
j'ai dit à mes parents vous inquiétez
pas c'est un contrat durée indéterminé
et en plus au bout de 2 mois j'étais à
35 he j'avais tout gagne en en terme de
salaire il y a aussi donc de quelle base
on part quelle évolution peut-être alors
bah on va dire si je peux me permettre
quand j'étais équipière donc j'avais le
SMIC horaire et au fur et à mesure en
fait en gravissant les les échelons bah
forcément le salaire évolue donc
aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai un salaire
totalement respectable qui est une base
donc mensuelle et tout tous les 3 mois
selon les résultats du restaurant nous
pouvons avoir une prime et nous avons en
plus le 13e mois on peut donner salaire
où il y a une confidentialité dessus moi
personnellement ça me dérange pas je
touche à peu près plus de 1500 € on va
dire c'est 1500 € net au minimum par
mois donc je pense que c'est déà des
résultat de fonction des résultats du
restaurant et si je travaille un petit
peu plus que prévu j'aurai un petit peu
plus de
sous très bien est-ce que vous auriez
quelques données peut-être local vous
parlez de 43000 emplois sur toute la
France
vous gérez en fait si départements six
restaurants dans le département je crois
se restaurants dans dans les Yvelines
donc effectivement qui représente à peu
près 460 salariés et donc on a
globalement on va recruter plus de 250
personnes pour renouveler et on va donc
aussi créer 50 emplois à partir de du
mois de septembre en ouvrant le site de
l'accue les yelin et nouveau restaurant
un nouveau restaurant et ce sont des
franchises à chaque fois comment ça
fonctionne le mode de fonctionnement
chaque restaurant un propriétaire qui
achète le nom ou pour ma part je
représente la l'enseigne donc ce sont
des restaurants qui qui effectivement
appartiennent à McDonald's et on a aussi
des des franchisés il a 30 il y a 30
restaurants dans les dans les yelines et
donc aujourd'hui SEP sont donc gérés par
la compagnie et le reste par les
franchisés donc c'est par vous-même
exactement vous avez signé également un
accord avec PUL emploi et le ministère
du Travail vous pouvez-nous dire un
petit peu de quoi il s'agit déjà
pourquoi ce cet accord bah tout
simplement pour bénéficier de bah des
des compét de de plan l'emploi et et
d'utiliser le leur méthode de
recrutement par simulation l'accord on
le précise c'est de d'embaucher 3000
personnes par an assurément tout à fait
voilà et donc en échange il il vous aide
à les trouver exactement et le le
recrutement justement vous cherchez quel
le type en quoi il vous aide en fait ben
ils nous aident tout simplement par les
méthodes de simulation on va avec eux
permettre de de pouvoir recruter des
personnes sans sans qualification et et
et par simulation donc vous n'êtes pas
amené vous-même à recruter des personnes
dans votre
restaurant vous peut-être c'est aussi
votre fonction oui oui nous sommes par
exemple managers nous pouvons être
formés justement au recrutement alors ça
dépend des restaurants moimême j'ai déjà
effectué des entretiens d'embauche et
j'ai déjà du coup on va dire poser des
équipiers à l'embauche à mon directeur
et sinon nous avons la responsable du
personnel ou le directeur bien souvent
qui gère les entretien pour le
recrutement voilà alors vous indiquiez
donc c'est souvent des personnes qui
sont peu diplômées vous l'étiez aussi
bien sûr vous aviez le bac je pense même
pas en entrant finalement la force aussi
finalement de cette ancienne c'est que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui sortir de
McDonald's avec un diplôme ouive exp
voilà avec la VAE alors c'est vrai VI
que donc McDonald's aujourd'hui nous
offre une belle opportunité donc nous
avons trois VAE disponibles pour les
équipiers c'est Agent polyvalent de
restauration pour les managers c'est le
BTS de Management des Unités
Commerciales et pour le directeur c'est
la licence c'est ça c'est une c'est un
diplôme type école de commerce c'est une
licence de gestion management je pense
tout à fait avec entre autres le
directeur de de Débora et a suivi cette
va donc un diplôme de la laaran Business
School ce son des diplômes que pouvez
faire valoir ensuite si vous changez
d'entreprise tout à faits di voà un
diplôme reconnu par les trois l'état
donc un cap un BTS ou un diplôécole
licences école de commce donc pour
résumer vous ne connaissez pas la
crise dans les restaurant McDonald's
voilà merci à vous d'être venu parler
emploi ce soir la chronique de l'écho se
poursuit avec quelques infos en plus et
oui la société pharmaceutique scomédica
basée à Montini est en cessation de
paiement depuis le 28 mars et fait
l'objet d'une procédure de redressement
judiciaire cette entreprise a été
rachetée en 2012 par le groupe américain
apricus bio elle promeut et distribue
des médicaments mais souffre clairement
d'une baisse du marché des médicaments
non génériques en France 90 salariés
pourrai perdre leur travail autre
information concerne le vélo le monde du
cyclisme oui 715000 c'est le nombre de
trajets quotidiens à vélo en
Île-de-France en 10ant ils ont été
multipliés par 2 ça la représente tout
de même 2 % des trajets effectués par
les habitants de la région pour
accompagner cette tendance la région
Île-de-France vient donc de voter 7,9
millions d'euros d'aide en tout genre en
faveur des circulations douces par
exemple des pistes cyclables des voiries
des plans de déplacement interentreprise
ou encore la création de consignes de
véloos sécurisé dans les gares on attend
donc de voir cette application à 5 ans
en Yveline et dans ses environs le Très
Haut Débit on en parle beaucoup mais
tout le monde n'y a pas encore accès
est-ce que ça va changer ça devrait
changer Orange SFR l'ont promis tous les
habitants d'Île-de-France devraient
avoir un accès à Internet d'ici 2020 il
faudra attendre un petit peu mais ça
devrait arriver un accord a été été
signé avec la région qui s'engage de son
côté à faciliter le raccordement et puis
pour conclure trois dates c'est l'agenda
c'est l'agenda la CGPME donc la
Confédération Générale du patronat des
petites et moyennes entreprises organise
le 18 avril un petit déjeuner
d'information àent la ville dans le
cadre du Forum de l'Emploi l'occasion
pour la directe qui la direction
régionale des entreprises de la
concurrence du travail et de l'emploi de
présenter ses dispositifs d'appui aux
entreprises et un éclairage sera
également donné sur les contrats de
génération et de
professionnalisation et puis jeudi
prochain la société ACS France organise
une journée porte ouverte dans ses
locaux à Buc elle présentera la Shotover
K1 qui est une caméra gostabilisée donc
pour faire pour être clair c'est une
caméra qui permet de filmer depuis un
hélicoptère par exemple priorité vous
l'aurez compris aux professionnels de
l'image oui on fait pas toujours des
prises de vue de cette façon oui c'est
sûr voilà ce n'est pas courant et puis
enfin Pierre Gatas qui est le candidat à
la présidence du meddeef fera une
conférence sur le thème pour un meddef
de combat de conquête et de
rassemblement c'est ouvert à tous
membres du meddeef ou non et puis c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer un des nombreux
candidats merci Claire pour ce point
complet sur l'économie à jeudi prochain